.
>> Tucker: IT IS NOT JUST FOR
ANYBODY, JULIO ROSE HAS COME
APPRECIATE IT.
WELL SEVERAL HUNDRED MOSTLY
SENIOR CITIZENS GOT FRUSTRATED
WITH THE ELECTION RESULTS IN
JANUARY AND BROKE THE LAW AND
WALKED TO THE U.S. CAPITOL
BUILDING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WERE SO AFRAID THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND SHE SAYS, THAT THEY
BUILT THE WALL IMMEDIATELY
AROUND THEIR WORKPLACE COME
AROUND THE CAPITAL.
THEY BROUGHT IN THE ARMY TO
PROTECT THEM.
MEANWHILE, OUR COUNTRY HAS NO
SOUTHERN BORDER EFFECTIVELY.
YOU JUST SAW THAT.
AND NO ONE IS DOING ANYTHING.
THAT IS TOTALLY FINE.
TOO BAD.
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHY ISN'T
THE STATE OF TEXAS STOPPING IT?
THEY ARE A BORDER TOO AND HAVE
THE NATIONAL GUARD.
WHY AREN'T THEY SHUTTING IT
DOWN?
THE AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER OF
TEXAS, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
NOW, I KNOW THESE PROBLEMS ARE
FAMOUSLY COMPLICATED BUT MAYBE
NOT THAT COMPLICATED.
WHY DON'T THEY SHUT DOWN THE
BORDER?
>> WE SHOULD AND I'M GLAD HE'S
DOING SOMETHING.
WE ARE FINALLY RESPONDING.
WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED FOR SEVEN
YEARS AND I'M HOPING IT'S NOT
POLITICAL THEATER BUT WE HAVE
THE BASIC QUESTIONS, YOU KNOW,
HIS PLAN.
WE NEED TO KNOW WHERE DOES THE
WALL NEED TO BE BUILT AND HOW
MUCH OF IT NEEDS TO BE BUILT?
AND HOW DO WE PAY FOR IT, THOSE
ARE FOUR BASIC QUESTIONS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN ANSWERED.
I'M GLAD HE'S DOING SOMETHING,
BUT WE ARE NOT DOING NEAR
ENOUGH.
THE PROBLEM I HAVE, TUCKER IS
THE TIMELINE.
WHEN NOVEMBER 4TH, 5TH, PICK A
DATE, JANUARY 6TH, WHEN LEGAL
AVENUES WERE CLOSED OR EVEN
JANUARY 20TH WHEN BIDEN WAS
SWORN IN, WE KNEW THERE WOULD BE
OPEN BORDERS.
AUNT SIX MONTHS AGO, THAT IS
WHEN WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
SOMETHING DOWN ON THE BORDER.
WE HAVE SCHOLL STOMACH ROLLED
OUT THE RAZOR WIRE WHERE THE
WALL HAD NOT BEEN BUILT.
WE SHOULD HAVE CONTRACTED A HIGH
SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT AND WE
SHOULD HAVE GOT OUR OWN DRONES
UP IN THERE TO SEE WHERE THE
SURGE IS COMING FROM.
ONCE THE SURGERY IS HERE, IT IS
TOO LATE.
WE COULD HAVE BEEN DOWN THERE ON
THE BORDER WHEN THE SEARCH GOT
HERE AND SAID "LOOK, WE DON'T
CARE WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYS, YOU'RE NOT
COMING INTO TEXAS."
>> Tucker: THAT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
MOST PEOPLE IN TEXAS REGARDLESS
OF POLITICAL AFFILIATION OR
ETHNICITY CAN APPRECIATE A A
COUNTRY WITH BORDERS.
AND ACTUALLY, PROTECTING OUR OWN
BORDERS IS PRESSING CONCERN.
WHAT IS PREVENTING
GOVERNOR ABBOTT WHO WANTS TO BE
REELECTED, HOPES TO IMAGINE BUT
I THINK HE DOES.
WHY ISN'T HE SENDING THEM IN
TONIGHT?
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
>> HE'S ONLY ONE THAT CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION HONESTLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE DOESN'T.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER.
I AM GLAD TO SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP
COMING BACK TO TEXAS.
HE IS WELCOME HERE.
HE WILL BE WELL RECEIVED IN THE
BORDER COMMUNITIES THERE.
THEY LOVE HIM DOWN THERE.
HE WON A LOT OF THOSE COUNTIES
AND CITIES IN THE LAST ELECTION
AND NEVER CARRIED BY A
REPUBLICAN BEFORE.
>> Tucker: THAT IS RIGHT.
>> WELCOME BACK MR. PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE OF THE
BORDER